what is success okay let's define
success is Success people having more
time on their hands to chill out and do
nothing is that what success is or is
Success building companies that creates
jobs that the government doesn't have to
come and bail people out the moment we
define success every single decision is
predicated based on the definition of
success the moment we do that okay so if
we go with the first one and we say
success is giving people more time on
their hands no problem let's investigate
that when you and I were kids okay I
have four kids you and I were kids when
we were kids what's the secret sauce
we've always heard parents did to
prevent kids from doing stupid [__] what
do they what do parents do how do you
keep your kids away from making dumb
decisions do you give them activities
after school such as what such as
reading a book you monitor their
homework Sports explore playing they're
playing basketball in the driveway with
their friends you know what they're
doing but they're active so let me ask
you this what happened when you and I
has kids had too much time on our hands
honestly I lit fires with magnifying
glasses and I burned what do we do if we
and I'm being very serious with you what
did we do
my brother
in the sports but okay for certain kids
they will get into more trouble no no
not for certain kids they will get in
trouble if you have more time on your
hands you having more time on your hands
you're going to get in trouble you are
going to do what you know drugs alcohol
ganks you know porn more video stupidity
the moment you have more time on your
hands fine okay so watch this a lady
who's a liberal from UCLA University
goes and does a study to see how much
free time
produces good things with people and you
know what number she figured out I'll
read it to you here because we have to
do the research on this based on a
project that we're working on here's
what she came up with this is a lady
named a modular homes they did a
research and a survey on 21 000
different people and this is the number
they found out okay they wanted to find
out at what point is your mental health
taken a shot the study was specifically
done when Cove would happen everybody's
being home they're like we got to figure
this part out how much free time is good
how much free time is bad here's what
you realize people need two hours of
free time why to be able to go out there
and do their you know your chores pay
the bills go get the haircut go do the
shop and all this other stuff if it's
less than two hours of free time a day
they have Stress and Anxiety it's not
good for them so you got an hour and a
half lunch and you got an hour a night
that's two and a half hours she said the
moment it went to five hours of free
time Stress and Anxiety went up why
because you started realizing am I not
valued am I not important can you not
use me to do productive things people
want to be valued if they're not being
used to be valued they see themselves as
I'm worthless I don't feel that good I
become bitter I have an attitude now
let's continue a little bit more with
this topic here on four day work week
okay so if we define success of
producing companies that did very well
the country in the world that they work
the least amount of hours a week you
know what country it is Italy it's
Netherlands you know how many hours a
week it's number one on the list 29
hours a week is what they work 29 hours
a week so we went through the bottom 10
smoking a lot of weed there in Amsterdam
no question about it again if we define
success as production that the world
benefits from your Innovation if that is
the definition of success you are not
going to do it at a 29 hour uh at a what
do you call it work week I agree at a uh
right there they're doing 27 and a half
hours the study I saw was 29 it's gone
down to 27 and a half hours the
Netherlands number one on the list
what's the least amount of work hours
they work
they're so industrial they've dropped
recently this is a recent number keep
going the Germans keep going keep going
Norway
Scandinavian
yeah
socialists keep going there they go
Europe
watch this here here's the question yeah
we looked at what companies they have
invented that has come out of their
countries that we've benefited from we
have benefited from the reason why
Europe can work as little as they do is
because we and to innovate they take
advantage of wow we fund NATO they sit
around and don't do [__] Europe is a
socialist Nation not a nation what do
you want to call it Nation Europe is
Europe Union they are they are
socialists because we allow them to
become socialists okay let me go to the
next one here some Industries where they
work with works not all Industries it
does there's another one it depends on
the face of a company if a company has
been around for 100 years it's a 100
billion dollar company they don't give a
[__] if you work four-day work week yeah
I mean we'll go they're already really
working for they work with there's so
many Executives I remember one insurance
company there was a guy that was making
a fat salary with this big ass insurance
company all of us know about you could
never get a hold of them you could never
do anything with them never called you
back never did anything work from home
is making a half a million a year not
doing [__] one day we had a meeting I
think you were part of that meeting do
you remember what happened in that
meeting very heated meeting you know
which one I'm talking about where I said
why the hell are you giving me a rep
like this that doesn't do [__] I said
let me tell you it doesn't call me back
doesn't do the guy got fired okay he had
to leave and he come and says what I
have to do it I can't nobody can ever
get a hold of you nothing you're not
supporting us there are a lot of major
companies you can do the four-day work
week maybe even mid-size you there's no
way in the world you can do four day
work week in a startup no way good luck
to you how the hell are you gonna do
four day work not gonna start up you're
not gonna do it so here's the point I
love it
if they convince people to voluntarily
go to a four-day work week you know why
because the people that are going to
voluntarily do six day work weeks game
over totally fine all the four day
people go to the four-day companies all
the five six day people that want to go
take over the world and make this and do
something impactful come to us we're
okay with that the level of consequences
on a four day work week is so massive
that all people are thinking about is
what is the next thing I can pitch for
people to vote for me so I can get
reelected and get another eight years of
salary and whatever else I need to be
doing it's a bunch of [__] but it's
very marketing was one of the main
reasons for all this situation all this
talk because people are like bro I'm
doing everything from home if I do come
in now I want to be here less than I
would have been before so let me stay
home for one more day am I am I am I
right knows what state was that media
company in that I was running when I had
to do all this California oh Cali oh and
did what is that group in Sacramento EDD
yeah they were just a pain but yeah so
you get regulated into this these things
that I did I did to accommodate to get
the job done to your customer service
but you know what my fantasy football
team for my for my employees Pat you're
absolutely right it's the people that
were there six days that was my fantasy
team yeah guess what though man this
listen I the only thing that concerns me
if it is mandatory if it's going to be
volunteer do it I say I'll vote for it
yeah I'll vote for it if you want to do
it volunteer if it's volunteer if it's
mandatory it's problematic by the way
let me add another thing to and I'll
wrap and I'll come to you early
retirement good thing or bad thing
well 55 years old or 62 years old or 60
is it a good thing or a bad thing no I
do not like let me read this to you
earlier early retirement before the age
of six I'm reading it to you from my
computer early retirement before the age
of 62 has been associated with higher
mortality rate risk in some instances a
study of Shell Oil Company watch this a
study of Shell Oil Company
found those who retire at 55 listen to
this Tom Tom listen to this Tom a study
of shell employees found that those who
retire at 55 lived to be 65 died 37
sooner than those who retired 65.
they're not doing anything they're just
stagnate those City retired 55 10 years
before 65 they died 37 sooner and in
general people will retire at 55 or 89
more likely to die within 10 years
that's those that retire at 55 or 89
percent more likely to die in within 10
years than those who retired 65. so four
day work week is a form of retirement as
well that's exactly what I said the
reason I held up those nine fingers
right there Pat where you were talking
is because I've heard after age 58 and
this is what this is saying retire
whenever you want you've not you got
nine years Wow that's scary that's crazy
that's what it's saying retire when
everyone after age 58 or later you have
nine years I thought why would you why
so why how would you correlate that to
what so are you saying because they're
just sitting wrong they're not they're
not active they're not doing anything
I want to feel important we are put here
to feel important you ever see these
protesters that go out there and scream
and yeah yeah you're like what the heck
that is a form of attention growth every
link important yeah okay we
teach our kids how to feel important if
the way they get our attention every
time they get in trouble they're always
going to get in trouble because that's
how they get your love yeah it's it's
the way we teach importance when you're
sitting around you got nothing you're
doing anything for you're not making an
impact you feel useless what the hell am
I living for maybe I'm no longer needed
you're you're right I'm no longer and
what am I we're checking out yeah I'm
checking out yeah wow so if I could add
to that
um absolutely right the number one thing
that I think everyone is looking for
everyone that's listening to this right
now is having meaning and purpose to
their life no doubt that's like above
work above starting a business
everyone's searching for that uh my
whole thing was I went from being sort
of when I was young not really trying to
work jack of all trades nightclubs
having fun here and there wasn't
concerned about money the exact opposite
of building a business and then I went
all in into the finance world and I'm
working ridiculous amount working it's
like burning the midnight hour making
cold calls just for like 10 years
grinding and then I look back and I'm
like holy [__] I've got money in the
bank I've got hundreds of thousands of
I'm a millionaire this is crazy and what
did I do at that point I took the pedal
off the metal and I went back I started
doing a four day work week I said
Fridays you can go [__] yourself like
don't call me I'm not answering the
phone I was living in South Beach
vacation time money in the bank I'm not
worried I'm chilling but that only lasts
for so long so at some point I said all
right I'm going to Mykonos I'm going to
Central pay I'm going to St Bart some
dating a girl she lives in Europe or
London I'm having a great time travel
travel the girl and I don't work out
what happens
I'm like all right I want to do
something I'm sick of the travel I've
done it I asked everybody's like how
often do you want to travel before it's
like I want to travel the world it's
like all right after you do that what
are you gonna do the rest of your life
is another world so then what I realize
is now is that like having meaning and
purpose in your life I started a little
Instagram show that Pat and I were like
this is years ago he's like dude start
doing stuff
I was like oh I like this and now I'm
doing two jobs working my ass off so
that Friday that I replaced now became
every Friday Saturday Sunday I'm working
on a side hustle because I I wanted to
have meaning and purpose in my life I
always say that my job is what I do it's
not who I am there's a big difference a
big disconnect this is a little bit more
who I am so money gives you options
right so what happens is as I'm doing my
job and I'm starting interviewing all
these wealthy people now the heckerling
financial conferences I started asking
the really really rich people the
Millionaires and the billionaires and I
said all right like after you get the
millions of billions like what do you do
do you just retire they're like retire
like I'm gonna do this forever like
because to Pat's credit
you want to have meaning and purpose in
your life it's not just about the money
and what I found out was that these
really wealthy people didn't just retire
and do nothing what did they do there's
three major things they travel they
pursue a passion starting a podcast
whatever right
or they give away their money and they
donate their money why because they want
to leave a legacy so there's different
phases I I just kind of walked you
through three phases at one phase of
just like party guy not worried about
[__] you know I don't care about money
to like holy [__] money's pretty
important let me do that I made money
let me take my pedal off the metal and
then you kind of get re-engaged with the
next phase of your career you're big on
chapters in your life Pat right zero to
twenty don't [__] it up you mean you can
you can kind of say what those things
are in there yeah but by the way Adam
you you're making a very good point
because you've experienced it right you
didn't have to do it and when you live
live like that by the way years go by so
quickly you ain't doing [__] all the
time four years went by yep not four
years one but waste of a life when you
do that for too long of a time but uh by
the way just to wrap this thing up I'll
just give you more logic side to this
what happens if a person's working five
days they go to four weeks four days
that's one on five is what twenty
percent right if a company loses 20
percent of Labor they have to hire 20 of
labor for the same amount okay so if
they go have to make up the other 20 of
hours that they're gonna need the labor
what happens then then I have to raise
my prices by 20 a five dollar burger
becomes six bucks okay a fifty thousand
dollar car has to become 60 Grand okay I
just have to do it because I gotta make
up that additional twenty percent that I
gotta go higher labor for people that
sell this from the manipulative way that
unions sell this thinking they're doing
the right thing they have no they don't
care about the person that's sitting
there what is going to happen on the
other end you think they care if price
is going to go up on 20 they're just
happy they're getting reelected doesn't
affect them that much and by the way I'm
gonna send you this thing take a look at
this year's states that uh population
change in 2022 show this chart if you
can rob uh on what happened I'm sending
it to your MacBook Pro I don't know if
you're seeing it or I'll send it to your
phone and the computer if you're seeing
it pull it up check this out and while
they're looking that up remember Union
skip get dues based on a little percent
based on what you earn they'd love you
to make more overtime and they'd love to
have more people making less they make
more that way 100 so guess what if you
can show this chart guys watch this here
not the pickle chart please rob we've
had enough pickles for today watch this
here look at this make it big so we can
see it you know what that is
that's the states that lost people and
states that gain people yeah California
keep doing stupid things keep doing it
people that are leaving you are the
people we want in Florida wow that's a
great chart the people that are leaving
you they're coming to States like ours
keep doing four day work week [__]
Union stuff driving the entrepreneur out
just like you keep losing people like
musk Rogan stick you know big job
creators keep leaving your first time
net you know of your population going
lower since 1851 you keep doing stuff
like that look at the North By the way
look on the other side look at
Pennsylvania look at New York look at
look at what they're going through look
at Illinois look at all those guys no
problem Oregon keep doing it Texas
winning Florida winning Arizona winning
Utah winning South Carolina winning
North Carolina winning
this is I would break this down to
losing people yeah I was going to say
break this down into 8 D20 rule like 80
percent of the map where people are
getting the hell out of are the over
regulated highly liberal blue States
typically right they're getting the hell
out of California or they're getting the
hell out of Oregon they're getting the
hell out of New York right Illinois all
that you know but on so absolutely right
they're moving to Florida Texas no doubt
but the flip side is the 20 percent
what the hell is going on in Louisiana
Mississippi West Virginia I mean nobody
wants any part of that you're nobody's
moving to these states very just just a
little food for thought nobody wants to
be part of a shitty State and so what
kind of rules are going on in those
states that are driving out their people
that's what I'm wondering we know what's
driving out people from liberal states
to more conservative States we know that
you know you know I'll tell you Adam
I'll tell you this give me the shittiest
State okay let me run it for 20 years
hear me out whatever you call as a
shitty State any one of these states let
us run it for 20 years it will be the
greatest state in America will attract
the best talent to come to our small
little state that we have I don't care
how big of a state that is listen bad
policies have consequences bad ideas
have consequences leadership good ideas
attracts people who go there because one
thing happens to create Gators doers and
creators are interested in one thing
they want to feel safe
they want to go to a state that they
feel safe trust me they can sit there
and say well I have to deal with
mosquitoes I have to deal with lizards I
have to deal with rabbits I have to deal
with this I have to deal with hurricane
I have to deal with tornado I have to
deal with I don't give you any crisis
you got in any state
free thinkers endures want to go to a
place that they're going to feel safe
that their ideas are not going to be
ripped apart and they're going to be
treated like [__] like California is
treating them no doubt period Scream by
the way you when people say well why is
California the top economy in the world
top economy in the in in America it's
the number four number five economy in
the world if it was a country because of
policies that came out 50 years ago not
right now the policy that came out 30
years ago not right now they're so into
deep now that those companies cannot
leave anymore you think you think if you
think if uh Bezos had to do it all over
again you think he would have gone to
Seattle what do you think no but it's
too late you kind of are stuck now
you're in Seattle across the street from
Microsoft yeah some of these things
happen New York and Wall Street he's
building headquarter two in Virginia
yeah massive after ao's yeah just
looking at this real quick if we had to
as a team with you as the leader take
over one of these states
no take it over I mean besides us where
would you where would you go on there
anywhere I don't
I don't care where you put it we'll get
the best people to come I believe it I
don't care where you put New Mexico you
are you about to make an announcement is
an announcement
I just bought New Mexico interests Pat
people are asking no no everyone wants
to know no no no no no no don't don't
create rumors I'm just saying like all
I'm saying is certain policies are gonna
attract those people I'd be go I would
be in California for a month straight in
a freaking RV driving up and down up and
down up and down up and down hey this is
Patrick David from the state of XYZ
we're here to talk to those of you that
are actually working yeah that are
feeling like you're paying too much
taxes we got a solution for you come to
our state come on now let me explain to
you what we're doing well no no no are
you sick and tired of the Union that's
what we'd be doing we would literally be
sitting there recruiting people don't
worry get on the bus we'll drive down to
our state and get on together here
that's what we be doing I love it and
we'd have a freaking Time Of Our Lives
but we're building a media company it's
a whole different story so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]